يوم الحد 23 يوليو الزميل العزيز الى
الماسك اغنى رجل في العالم حاليا طلع قرار
رسمي بتغيير اسم تويتر منصه التواصل
الاجتماعي الشهيره اللي انشاها في 2006
جاك دورس وبيستون
القرار ده معناه انه هيرمي شعار العصفور
الازرق اللي هو تقريبا اشهر رمز لاي منصه
تواصل اجتماعي في اي مكان وكل الكلمات
التعريفيه المرتبطه به وعلى راس الكلمات
دي الكلمه الاشهر برضو تغريده وهيقول
لشكله مضمون المنصه كلها مع السلامه في
تتويج لسلسله التغييرات الضخمه اللي عملها
لكم شهر اللي فاتوا التقديرات الاوليه من
برج بتقول ان خطوه ايلون ماسك دي مسحت
باستيكه ما بين اربعه وعشرين مليار دولار
من قيمه العلامه التجاريه لتويتر في السوق
علامه مش عاديه اكتسبت تقلها بين
المستخدمين في انحاء العالم على مدار ال
17 سنه اللي فاتوا من لحظه الاطلاق في
2006 اكتر شيء مميز فيها كان شعار الطائر
الازرق ده طبعا دي خساره كبيره لو صحت
خاصه لما تحط في اعتبارك انه في مايو اللي
فات شركه في داله الباسمنس المعروفه
الاستثمارات قيمت تويتر ب 15 مليار دولار
بس بعد التغييرات وقررت ايلون ماسك في
الشهور اللي فاتت وتقييم في داليتي
بالمناسبه هو تقريبا نفس تقييم مصر اللي
قال فيه في نفس الفتره ان تويتر بيساوي
اقل من نص التمن اللي اتدفع فيه اللي هو
كان اربعه واربعين مليار دولار اللي حصل
ده جاب استنكار كبير من عدد لا باس به من
خبراء الدعايه والتسويق والاعلام الرقمي
والقطاع المالي وبعضهم يتعامل مع اللي
بيحصل على انه المسمار الاخير في نعش
تويتر وجنازت الموقع بقت على الابواب خلاص
بينما لهون ماسك على الناحيه التانيه او
بصيت عليه هتلاقيه ولا كانه من هنا شايف
الكلام ده كله وبيتصرف بمنتهى اللامبالاه
وبيعمل اللي في دماغه طب ليه علشان عنده
حلم مختلف بيتكلم عنه من اكتر يعني عشرين
سنه حلم بتاسيس وامتلاك اكبر مؤسسه ماليه
في العالم مؤسسه بتتحكم في نص النظام
المالي العالمي زي ما هو قلب نفسه وشراء
تويتر اللي هو بالمناسبه اجبر عليه بعد ما
حاول يتراجع عن الصفقه قبل ما يتمها هو
الشيء اللي هيسرع له تحقيق حلمه ده دي
رؤيته لكل اللي بيحصل فايه اللي بيحصل
بالظبط في تويتر وايه علاقته بالنظام
المالي العالمي وبينا وهل الوان ماسك عنده
خطه عبقريه ولا الموضوع مجرد حلم هيفوق
منه على كارثه حقيقيه تعالوا ندردش شويه
واحكي لكم الحكايه انا اشرف ابراهيم
[موسيقى]
عايز اشكر شركه اكسناس العالميه لرعايتها
الحلقه دي وهي شركه عندها خبره طويله في
الاسواق الماليه بحجم تداولات شهريه تجاوز
الاتنين تريليون دولار ليه بنصح بالتعامل
مع علشان اربع مميزات الاولى انها مرخصه
ومراقبه من هيئات رقبيه التانيه بعرف اسحب
فلوسي فيها بشكل فوري بدون تدخل بشري
الثالثه ان عملتهم منخفضه الرابعه ان
التداول بيتنفس بسرعه تقدر تفتح حساب
اسلامي لا محدود وتبدا تشتري وتبيع الاسهم
والدهب هتلاقوا لينك لهم تحت الفيديو وفي
تعليقات فيسبوك خلوني الاول بس احكي لكم
بسرعه على اللي حصل الايام اللي فاتت ليله
السبت 22 من شهر يوليو زميل ماسك اعلن عن
التغيير في كم تغريده على حساب الشخصي
اللي بيتابعوا عليه اكتر من 150 مليون شخص
وصادر القرار الرسمي يوم الحد يوم الاثنين
كانت تغيير متطبق على الموقع كله رئيس
تويتر التنفيذيه اعلنت ان اكس كارب هيكون
موقع لكل شيء للمحتوى المر المكالمات
الصوت والرسائل والتواصل الاجتماعي والدفع
وتحويل الاموال وهكذا في نفس اليوم الشركه
جابت عمال علشان يشيلوا كلمه تويتر من على
مبنى المقر الرئيسيكو وهنا حصل موقف
كوميدي حبتين لازم اوريه لكم تغيير الاسم
كان سريع وعفوي لدرجه ان ما حدش اهتم يبعت
لاداره التخطيط قسم فحص المباني في مدينه
سان فرانسيسكو طلب التغيير واداره المبنى
اللي ماجره تويتر اعترضت على ده لان لازم
مسؤول الشركه يستاذنوهم قبل عمل اي تغيير
في المبنى بموجب عقد الايجار علشان كده
والعمال بيشيلوا الاسم الشرطه وصلت بناء
على مكالمه من اداره المبنى وطلبوا من
العمال يوقفوا اللي بيعملوه ده وساعتها
سابوا حرفين بس اي ار وبعدها شالوا جنب
واحد زي ما شايفين قدامكم ويوم الجمعه
اللي فاتت اتحطوا علامه اكس الجديده عباره
عن معدن مجسم بشكل سريع على المبنى فيما
يبدو ان تحدي لاداره المبنى والمدينه
نفسها اللي قسم فحص المباني فيها فتح
تحقيق بيحصل طب نسيبنا من الكوميديا دي
ونرجع للاساس ايه اللي بيحصل في حالات
معروفه لنا كلنا لشركات كبرى اعاده تسميه
نفسها في الكم سنه الاخيره اشهرهم جوجل
اللي تحولت لالفا بيت وكان السبب الواضح
ان الشركه الام عاوزه الشركات التانيه
المختلفه جواها تنمو من غير ما ترتبط
ببرند محرك البحث الاشهر فيسبوك برضو حول
نفسه لميتا وكان السبب الاساسي هو التاكيد
للمستثمرين وللعالم على التزام الشركه
الكامل بانشاء عالم ميتافيرس اللي بيحلم
به مارك زوكربيرج زائد نفس سبب جوجل ان
منتجات الشركه التانيه ما تكونش مرتبطه
بفيسبوك لكن حاله تويتر مختلفه جدا
الاختلاف الاهم فيها ان تويتر سابقا اكس
حاليا ببساطه ما عندوش غير منتج واحد هو
المنصه نفسها في كم شهر اللي فاتوا ماسك
اتحرك بسرعه مهوله علشان نحط بصمته على
المنصه ويفرض رؤيته ويغير ده عمل ايه بقى
خفض القوه العامله في تويتر بنسبه 80%
وطرد معظم المديرين التن ورؤساء الاقسام
وساب حوالي الفين موظف بس وخلى التوثيق
باشتراك شهري للجميع بعد ما كان مقتصر على
فئات معينه اللي هم المؤثرين او المملك
فيجرس في مختلف المجالات وفتح الباب
لتغييرات ضخمه في سياسات المحتوى ورجع
كتير من الحسابات اللي سبق وقفلتها اداره
تويتر القديمه وعلى راسها حساب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب كل دخل لوضع
تويتر المالي سيء من ساعه ماسك نفسه قال
لي تويتر في اكتوبر اللي فات 2022 فقد
اكتر من 50% من ايراداته من الاعلانات
اللي هي بتمثل 91 ونصف في الميه من
الارباح قبل ما ماسك يستحوذ عليه مباشره
وعدد لا باس بيهم الخبراء والمحللين اجمع
ان تويتر فقط حوالي 32% من قيمته بعد
استحواذ ماسك عليه وماسك برضو الف نوفمبر
بعد ما مسك وبدا تخفيض العماله بشكل واسع
ان تويتر بيخسر في اليوم اكتر من اربعه
مليون دولار وانه ما عندوش اي خيارات
تانيه غير التصفيه الواسعه التغييرات دي
كلها كانت مزعجه جدا لعدد لا باس به من
مستخدمي الموقع وعدد من كبار معلنيه اللي
انسحبوا زي ما قلت لكم لخوفهم من تاثير
اللي بيحصل على سلامه حياديه علاماتهم
التجاريه زي ما قالوا ولكن التغييرات دي
كانت محببه لفئه من متابعين اللي كانوا
متضايقين من سياسات الصوت الواحد اللي
كانت مسيطره على معظم مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وبالتالي برجعهم تاني وكان طبعا
عامل جذب لمشجعي فريق مصر وهما الناس اللي
بيقيدوه وبيحبوه شعبيه الزميل ماسك
بالمناسبه مخليه بعض الخبراء بيعتقدوا
بشده ان الراجل كابراند في نفسه هو اقوى
من برنت تويتر ويمكن ده العمل الرئيسي او
الوحيد كمان اللي مد بعض الناس وعلى راسهم
الى نفسه ثقه في نجاح كل اللي حصل واللي
هيحصل ده لدرجه ان ماسك نفسه توقع من كم
شهر ان قيمه تويتر في المستقبل القريب
هتوصل ل 250 مليار دولار طب برده ايلون
ماسك من كل ده الراجل ببساطه عايز يستخدم
تويتر ويخليه اداه قويه تقدر تسرع تحقيقه
لحلمه بوجود تطبيق كل شيء قبل ايه هو
تطبيق كل شيء ده بقى هو باختصار تطبيق
واحد بتقدر تعمل من خلاله كل حاجه تبعت
رسايل تتصل بحد صوت وصوره تقدم محتوى
مكتوب ومرئي عليه تحول وتستقبل فلوس من
عليه تركب من عليه مواصلات تتداول من عليه
تطلب من عليه مشتريات مختلفه تدفع من عليه
فواتير وتحجز مواعيد كل حاجه تقريبا في
انشطتنا اليوميه طيب هل ماسك صحي من النوم
وقرر ده فجاه كده الحقيقه حلم ماسك مش
وليد الكام شهر اللي فات دول ولكنه بيرجع
لاواخر التسعينات ايوه الراجل عنده رؤيه
تحديدا من ساعه ما اشترى نطاق اكس دوت كوم
في سنه 1999 ساعتها كان مشتريه علشان يكون
مشروع الخاص بالمدفوعات بعدها اندمج بشركه
المدفوعات كوم
سنه 2000 علشان تطلع للنور شركه المدفوعات
الماليه الاشهر عالميا عبر الانترنت بيبقى
واللي كانت اساس لثروه ماسك الحاليه بعد
23 سنه يبدو لسه مصر على الاسم ولسه مصر
على مشروع العملاق ده ماسك ببساطه وزي ما
قال هو نفسه قبل كده عاوز يعمل تطبيق
ما يعرفش ويتشات فهو تطبيق صيني بتملكه
شركه القابضه المحدوده اكبر شركه
تكنولوجيا رقميه اسيويه واحده من اطخن
شركات التكنولوجيا في العالم والقيمتها
السوقيه اكثر من 440 مليار دولار التطبيق
بيستخدمه قرابه واحد فاصل سبعه مليار
مستخدم وبيجمع بين خدمات كتيره ضمن تطبيق
واحد قوي جدا زي المكالمات والرسائل وانه
في حد ذاته منصه تواصل اجتماعي بالاضافه
لتحويل الفلوس ودفع الفواتير وحجز
المواعيد عند الدكاتره وطلب المواصلات
وخلافه علشان كده بيسموه في الصين تطبيق
كل شيء
وبيسموه برضو في التطبيق الخارق او سوبر
اب في مثال تاني في اسيا برده هو تطبيق
جراب وهو شركه تكنولوجيا متعدده جنسيات
مقرها في سنغافوره وبتقدم خدمات توصيل عن
طريق المشاركه وتوصيل الاكل والخدمات
الماليه في دول جنوب شرق اسيا وتحديدا دول
سنغافوره وماليزيا وكانبوديا من النار
واندونيسيا وتايلاند والفلبين فيتنام في
ماسك بقى عاوز يعمل تطبيق زيد اوب بس
بالنفس والحضور والقوانين الامريكيه
والاوروبيه هتقول لي اشرف ما ده كلام جميل
فين المشكله بقى اقول لك هي مش مشكله بقدر
ما هو عدم واقعيه او تشكك من قبل
المعترضيه الا هو بيقولوا له ببساطه كان
غيرك اشطر طب ليه يا اخواننا قال لك لكذا
صعبه اولا اذكى من ماسك وعندهم موارد اكتر
حاولوا فشلوا او لقوا ان تطبيق لكل شيء مش
خيار جذاب بالمره من الناحيه التجاريه
بيزنس سوايس لو ركزنا مثلا مع
هنلاقي فيها جوجل كمحرك بحث ويوتيوب وجوجل
مابس وجميل يوتيوب نفسه هنلاقي في تطبيق
يوتيوب الاساسي ويوتيوب للاطفال استوديو
اليوتيوب لصنع المحتوى الى اخره كل حاجه
لها تطبيق منفصل لان ده بيقلل تكاليف
الصيانه وبيرفع نسب التركيز على التطوير
وبيحسن من عمليه التطوير نفسها وبيضمن عدم
وقوع المنظومه كلها لو وقع اي جزء فيها
لاي سبب اما بعد تطبيق اللي بيحاول يعمل
كل حاجه ده فغالبا هيواجه مشاكل اكتر
وهيكون بطيء وزحمه ثانيا بقى المستهلك
الغربي اصعب وارخم من المستهلك الاسيوي
لما بيمسك في خدمه او تطبيق وبيريحه يكون
عنده ولاء ليه مش بيسيبه بسهوله ابدا ده
مش عيب بالمناسبه طبيعي لما مزود الخدمه
اللي بستخدمها وتكون مهتم باحتياجاتي
وبتقييم الدائم لخدمته وبيطورها باستمرار
يكون ولائي ليه ومش هسيبه بسهوله الامر
الثالث بقى ان المستهلك الغربي برده مش
بيحب
الواقع ان الزبون الغربي خاصه الامريكي
واللي ماسك عاوز يستهدفه بطبيعه الحال ما
عندوش فقر او قله اختيارات في مساحه تحويل
الاموال والاقتراض وخلافه بالعكس عنده
خيارات كتير بره النطاق البنوك وقبل ده
طبعا في مساحه البنوك نفسها اللي هي
المساحه الاساسيه للمستهلك الغربي واللي
عنده فيها الاف الخيارات المختلفه حتى
برغم وجود عيوب كتيره في الخيارات دي
فمعضله ماسك الرئيسيه هنا مثلا هتكون في
انه ازاي هيكسب ثقه العملاء علشان ياتمنوا
تطبيقه على فلوسهم خارج نطاق المعجبين به
ولكن برغم كل اللي فات ده ففي بعض الواجهه
في الخطوه الجذريه اللي عملها ماسك تويتر
مؤخرا وهي تغيير اسمه
احد مؤسسه تويتر الضمنيا ان لما ماسك
اشترى تويتر براند كان مطرب بمعنى انه كان
مليان سلبيات ومشاكل وعليه ديون ومش مواكب
للتطورات وبالتالي يمكن بدايه دي كبدايه
جديده
قرار احسن من الناحيه العمليه يعني ناس في
القفص اللي في العصفور كان ضروري لبدايه
جديده للمنصه علشان كده ماسك نفسه كان
واضح لما قال نصا ان هويه تويتر القديمه
ما بقتش بتعبر عن الموقع بعد التغيرات
الكبرى اللي طالته في كل شيء تقريبا وان
اسمه تويتر كان منطقي لما كان مقتصر على
140 حرف بس في رساله لكن دلوقتي اي حد
يقدر ينشر اي شيء باي طول تقريبا بما في
ذلك فيديوهات طويله وافلام كامله وكمل
وقال انه في الشهور الجايه هيضيفه للمنصه
امكانيه اجراء مكالمات مطوله وهيكون كل
شخص قادر على اداره اعلمه المالي بالكامل
زي ما قال فعلشان كده اسمه تويتر ما بقاش
منطقي ولازم نودع العصفور الازرق للابد
الحاجه التانيه اللي ممكن تبقى في صالح
ماسك هي القاعده البسيطه جدا اللي يعرفها
معظمنا وهي بيزنس اسبيزنس يعني لو الموقع
سواء اسمه تويتر او اكس او حكشه بيجيب
مستخدمين وبيقعدوا عليه وقت طويل هو روتين
يومهم والمستخدمين دول مش فارق معهم براند
الموقع طالما بيديهم خدمات بتريحهم فده
هيترجم بالضروره لفلوس بمعنى ان معظم
الشركات والمعلنين مش هيسيبوا فرصه الوصول
لجمهور ضخم زي بتاع اكس تويتر سابقا علشان
مختلفين مع ماسك وتوجهاته وارائه المهم
عندهم دايما هيكون الارباح بطبيعه الحال
ويمكن ده من اسباب الرئيسيه والمهمه جدا
اللي خلت مش مهتم للدرجه بالضجه اللي حصلت
في اول اسبوع نزل فيه تطبيق بتاع المعلم
مارك زوكربيرج علشان ينافس تويتر طبعا
اللي حصل بياكد نظره ماسك الثاقبه ان
التطبيق المنافس الجديد ما كانش بالخطوره
اللي بادى عليها اول ما طلع وده بيتاكدوا
الاحصائيات والارقام دلوقتي خاصه بعد
الانخفاض السريع والحاد اللي حصل لفريدس
بعد اول اسبوع سواء في عدد المستخدمين
النشاطين على التطبيع حاليا واللي هم
حوالي 13 مليون مستخدم ودي تقريبا نسبه
انخفاض تج 70% من اجمالي اللي سجله او حتى
على مستوى عدد دقائق البقاء على سريدس بعض
التقارير كشفت انها انخفضت لمتوسط بقاء
اربع دقائق فقط في اليوم للمستخدم الواحد
الحاجه الاخيره اللي عاوز الفت انتباهكم
لها هي انه الماسك واحد من الاشخاص
القليلين جدا في العالم اللي عندهم رفاهيه
الفشل بمعنى انه ممكن يجرب ويستثمر ويطلع
وينزل ويخسر ويحاول تاني وثالث الراجل
حرفيا متعود على الشقلبه ده بالاضافه الى
انه مش لوحده يعني رفاهيه دي مش جايه من
خلال ثروته بس زي ما بيتصور معظمنا وانما
من دايره علاقاته بالمستثمرين واصحاب
الاعمال في كل مكان في العالم وقدرته على
اقناعهم بالاستثمار في افكاره ومشاريعه
المجنونه والطموحه بناء على نجاحاته في
اضخم مشاريع الحاليه زي تسلا وسبيس اكس
وغيرهم ده بيدي له حريه حركه واسعه وقدره
كبيره على التعافي من الخساره علشان كده
ما نقدرش نستبعد انه ممكن يعملها فعلا
وينجح في تحقيق حلم تطبيق كل شيء وده
تقريبا الشيء الوحيد اللي ما فيش شركه
امريكيه او اوروبيه عرفت تعمله في الاسواق
الصعبه بتاعتهم لحد اللحظه مش عاوزه اطول
عليكم لحد هنا انا خلصت كلامي وكالعاده
عندي سؤال لحضراتكم تفتكروا الزميل العزيز
ماسك ممكن ينجح فعلا في بناء تطبيق كل شيء
وتحويله لاكبر مؤسسه ماليه عالميه ولا دي
احلام العصاري بس وهيفوق منها قريب هتابع
كل اجاباتكم في التعليقات اللي عايز يشتري
اسهم او ذهب ما تنسوش تشوفوا شركه اكسنس
هتلاقوا رابط تحت الفيديو ما تنسوش
تشتركوا في القناه ويا ريت لو عودتكم
الحلقه تعملوا لايك وشير للفيديو واهم
حاجه تحكو لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا يمكن
نستفيدوا سلام
[موسيقى]